we are told a rocket is launched from a
platform its height in meters x seconds
after the launch is modeled by
h of x is equal to negative 4 times x
plus 2 times x minus 18. now the first
thing they ask us is what is the height
of the rocket at the time of launch
pause the video and see if you can
figure that out
well what is x at the time of launch
well x is the number of seconds after
the launch so at the time of launch x
would be equal to zero so the height of
the rocket when x is equal to zero
they're essentially saying well what is
h of zero and to figure out h of zero we
just have to go back to this expression
and replace all the x's with zeros so h
of 0 is going to be equal to negative 4
negative 4 times
0 plus 2 which is just going to be 2
times 0 minus 18 which is just going to
be
negative 18.
and so let's see this is going to be
negative 8 times negative 18
negative 8 times negative 18 which is
the same thing as negative 8 times
negative 9 times 2
so this is going to be positive 72 times
2 which is 144.
so 144
meters did i do that right let's see
we're going to have yep that sounds
right that's right how many seconds
after launch will the rocket hit the
ground so pause this video again and see
if you can answer that
well what does it mean for the rocket to
hit the ground that means that the
height is equal to zero
so if you want to figure out how many
seconds after launch how many seconds
that's x so we want to figure out the x
when our height is equal to zero so we
can set up an equation let's make our
height h of x equals zero so zero is
equal to negative four
times x plus two
times
x minus eighteen
well if you have the product of three
different things being equal to zero
you the way you get this to be equal to
zero is if at least one of these strings
is equal at least one of these three
things is equal to zero well negative
four can't be equal to zero so we could
say x plus two
equals zero i got that from
right over here so if x plus 2 were
equaling 0 then this equation would be
satisfied and so that would be the
situation when x is equal to negative 2
but remember x is the number of seconds
after the launch so a negative x would
mean b going before the launch so we can
rule that one out and then we could also
think about well x minus 18 if that's
equal to 0 then this entire expression
could be equal to 0.
so x minus 18 equals 0 you add 18 to
both sides you get x is equal to 18.
so
18 seconds after launch well we're going
forward in time 18
seconds after launch we see that our
height is zero we have hit the ground
next question how many seconds after
being launched will the rocket reach its
maximum height pause the video again and
see if you can figure that out
well the key realization here is if you
have
if you have a curve if you have a
parabola in particular and it's going to
look something like this
if you're going to have a parabola that
looks something like this you're going
to hit your maximum height right over
here between your two
zeros or between the two times that your
height is zero so if you figure out this
this x value and this x value the
average of the two will give you your x
value the time after launch when you're
at your maximum height well we already
figured out what this x value is and
what this x value is we know that h of x
is equal to 0 when x is either equal to
so that is x is equal to 18 or
x is equal to negative 2.
so that is x is equal to negative 2. so
to answer this question we just have to
go halfway between negative 2 and 18. so
let's do that
so
negative 2
plus 18
divided by 2
gets us what that's going to be 16 over
2 which is going to be equal to 8. so
this is right over here this is x equals
8 seconds the
our rocket is at its maximum height
last question what is the maximum height
that the rocket will reach once again
pause the video and try to answer that
well we already know from the previous
question that we reach our maximum
height when x is equal to 8 8 seconds
after launch and so to figure out the
height then we just have to evaluate
what h of 8 is
h of 8 remember that's what this
function does you give me any x value
any elapsed time after launch and it
will give me the height so 8 seconds
after launch i know i have maximum
height to figure out that height i just
input it into the function so h of 8 is
going to be equal to negative 4
times
8 plus 2
times 8 minus 18.
8 plus 2 is 10. 8 minus 18 is negative
10 and so you have negative 4 times
negative 100 so that's going to be
positive
400 and h is given in meters so that's
its maximum height 400 meters